Arrays now have a .find and a .
findIndex, which are really
helpful. Some of my projects I
don't even need to load in a
utility library like lodash.
Let's take a look at what find
and findIndex do. A very common
use case is when you have some
data that comes back from an API.
Here I've got some data that
comes back from Instagram. It's
a posts array, where each item
inside of the post is an object.
Often we'll have something like,
let's take this one. BAF_KY4
blah, blah, blah, blah, and we
want to find the entire object
inside of this array. Now,
because it's an object, we can't
simply say post.the ID of the
object. We can't say anything
like posts or something like
that, because we don't have any
keys to grab things from an
array because an array is always
indexed based. What we
actually need to do is we will
say, const post equals, we'll
take the post, and we'll call .
find on it. Now, find is a
callback where you return true
or false until you actually find
it. It's going to loop over
every single post that we have,
and I'm going to look for the
specific one that I want. I'm
going to open up a hop log here
and then I'll refactor that
because we don't actually need
it. Let's say I'm going to grab
this one, VBGT, and I'm going to
console.log the post. Let's just
see where we're at here. OK,
what this is doing is it is
looping over every single one
and giving me the entire post.
Then I want to say post.code,
should give me all of the codes.
Then I want to say if post.code
is equal to the one that we're
looking for, then we will return
true. Otherwise, we just can
return, or return false
explicitly. Then I think
that what that should do to us
is, we should now have a
variable called post, and that
is the actual one from our
object, so now we have the
entire post and we can go ahead
and grab the caption, or the
source, or the ID or the number
of likes from that Instagram
post. This can be done a lot
easier. This is just explicit,
so you can see what's going on,
but we can actually just use
this. For each post we say, does
the post.code equal to the
actual one that we're looking
for? Again, I'm just going to
grab an ID here, and paste it in
there. We should be able to just
console.log that post. One
other improvement we can do is
this probably isn't hard coded
like that. We probably want to
put in a variable called code,
stick it like that, and then it
should be able to still find the
post, depending on our code.
Great. That is good for finding
the actual thing inside of the
array. If you want to find
multiple, how would you do that?
You would use .filter, and that
would give you an array of
objects instead. Next up, we
have .findIndex. That's really
helpful when you actually have
the item you want, but you want
to know where in the array is it
actually? What we want to do
is, let's say we want to delete
one of these posts, and all that
we know is that we have the ID
or the code right here. We need
to find out where in this is it,
so we can delete it. I'm going
to say, const post index equals
post.findIndex. Again, I'm
going to do it longhand. We'll
say, if post.code equal to code,
then return true. Otherwise, we
can just do nothing, return, or
return false explicitly. Now we
should be able to find what the
index is of that post. It's the
22nd post in there. We can
also now go back and just say...
we don't need these extra
parentheses here. We don't need
this entire thing. Why? Because
we can only return as the post.
code is equal to our code.
Now that we actually have the
index, we could go ahead and
just take that out of there.
We're going to look at a spread
example in the future where it
shows a great way, how do you
just slice out one item from an
array.